now
how did your world view
or your perspective on politics
when you were younger get changed when
you got into the cia
because i believe on one of your
podcasts you talk about your parents
were hippies yeah yeah
yes and they raised you you had a very
liberal progressive mindset
yeah before you entered the cia so my
progression was
my parents are very liberal both of them
still
and then i went to undergrad and i hung
out with tons of people
who were like left of liberal who were
they called
progressive as was the word and i was
very progressive and then
i went to law school and law school was
the first time
where i it was
a smaller environment so my undergrad
was a very large school so you kind of
pick your niche and you hang out with
those people right it's like
how people tend to hang out with
like-minded folks
law school was smaller so i was forced
to hang out with
whoever was there and then i was forced
to hear all these
other perspectives and other
perspectives from people who are
intelligent enough to explain them
so suddenly i'm hearing not just another
person's perspective
not like a regurgitation of a bumper
sticker
yeah exactly but people who like could
defend their ideas
people who were open to hearing other
people's ideas right like the whole
point
when you practice law is creating a
solid argument but that argument can go
either way
right i mean that's what you have
prosecution and defense you have
two sides constantly so you're
constantly practicing
making both sides of the argument and it
was this really
powerful exercise for me like three
years of constantly
having to think about both sides of an
argument and that was the point where i
started to shift
center um and you were meeting more
like some some folks were there were
some older students there some people
had different life experiences so you're
starting to be exposed to
different kinds of people and then when
i got to agency
the agency is full of brilliant people
really just sharp intelligent patriotic
um you know people like i had had
friends from all over the world before
but suddenly i'm with
people who not only are from all over
the world but are
like very american as well so so i
started getting this much broader
perspective of
government and government's role and how
other countries are perceived
and i didn't agree with everything there
i mean there are still some things where
you know i i i think it's really
important
for intelligence and diplomacy to be
able to step into the shoes
of another culture of another country
and that didn't always happen there
some people were much too um like if you
talk to some state department workers
you'll see
you'll see it too where they're much too
america forward
and i feel like that's a mistake like
you need to keep that perspective
because that is your goal like your
your mission is to represent and do
what's best for america but if you can't
understand what the russians or the
chinese are thinking and feeling
you're you're gonna miss it you know
you're gonna miss the mark
so um like on like you have to
understand motivations and
vulnerabilities and that's really the
only way to do it
so when i met when i started working
with all these amazing people
at the caa um my
perspective was just broadened i think
and then i met people
you're not supposed to be um
political there and so there was much
less you're not supposed to be
no okay yeah um yeah we are i mean i
think any federal government agency
is like that you're not suppose you are
supposed to represent the government
the government changes political parties
constantly
um so you're not really supposed to like
like there aren't a lot of conversations
where people are like
you feel like you're inundated with
liberal ideas or inundated with
conservative ideas people just speak
their mind they speak in an intelligent
way
and there's always reasoning behind it
and for me that's
you know there has to be there has to be
depth
to the conversation like if you just
start if somebody's just
spewing ideas there's there has to be
more
more to that right it makes you think is
that where we we could be going
if we last that long you know it's
really interesting i
i so i'm a giant dork and i am a huge
fan
of star trek and like star trek next gen
is
one of my favorites and so the whole
idea that one day we could be like this
you know utopia on earth at least where
you know like money isn't like i think
there's no currency i'm pretty sure in
star trek
everybody has roles they fill
everybody's needs are mad
there's this definite part of me that's
like that could happen one day
in theory but communism
is also a good theory and
like practically it will probably never
ever work
um so it's it's one of those things
where you know i have faith in humanity
but i'm also
realistic you know we could do a lot of
things
lots of things are possible are we ever
going to get there i don't know
it would be i mean it just seems like
the world would be such a better place
if but
if we didn't have this inherently tribal
dna
where we're just not like we said like i
said earlier like territorial apes with
thermonuclear weapons yeah and
you know unfortunately that's just what
we
are as human beings and i i
can't see in the near future
any way to get past that threshold yeah
but i figured out
what if we could somehow figure out how
to get past that i think
you know like i said your vision of some
utopian
world of people that all get along and
there's no borders or boundaries and
right i mean i i agree with you i think
near future
i don't see it um is it is it possible
yes there is a ton of work that would
need to be done
i think i was just reading a book that
was talking about
um like the scarcity mindset
and the scarcity mindset is what drives
people to
hoard and to compete and to be like you
know there might be five apples and five
of us but i'm gonna
take three just in case and like that
that mindset gets us all in trouble like
if you
look at if you really looked at
resources and how they could be divvied
out like if we actually
entertained all the options that were
possible
there really would be enough um for
everybody like there would at least be
enough for basics for everybody
but that doesn't seem to be good enough
for enough people
like people who have control people who
have leverage
so that just makes you know creates
inequality it keeps inequality going
um so yeah i just i think it's a long
road i think it's definitely possible
i think people are working towards it
what do you think the best way
for people to get out of that scarcity
mindset
is so i think it's just
believing that there is enough believing
like
not being scared that at the end of this
like when i finish my sandwich
there will be no more sandwich like just
don't be afraid right like
just know that i'm gonna eat this meal
and by the time the next meal needs to
come around
it'll be there there's enough right like
maybe it's not gonna be a
you know maybe it's not gonna be a steak
and a giant baked potato
but it will be enough like you will eat
you will be fed
um so just knowing you know like
investing money right like
don't hoard your money like use it
because there
will be more on the other end you know
like if you keep
working and you keep moving forward then
you're not going to be without
i